progress bars how many of them we see
every day you download something you get
progress bar you install a new program
there you go even now while you're
watching this video there is a cursor
here on YouTube player saying that which
point of this video you're at and that
is another example of a progress bar
however have you ever thought about it
the question is like what is a progress
bar it's a graphical element that
indicates the progression of a task
sometimes it give you you know some
extra bit of information such as the ETA
which although it stands for estimate
the time of arrival it provides you with
a rough estimate how much time is left
till the operation at hand will be
completed the story of progress bar
dates back the birth of computers in the
19th centuries a Polish management
research came up with something called
horm monogram or monograph which showed
production schedules so this idea didn't
take off because it was a piece of
research written in Polish and very few
people knew about it later somebody
called Harry Gant came up with a similar
concept called the gun chart which
everybody still today us it so yeah a
progress bar can be seen as a direct
descendant of Gart which were invented
around in the 1910 back in the days they
were used to maximize the production in
a munition manufacturer company now
basically we use in operating system to
see if something's completely like
installing a program progress bars can
take many forms as I mentioned before it
can be you know a rectangle fields or a
spinner just to mention a few sometimes
they work backward what I mean by
backward think of a battery indicator in
your smartphone and sometimes a progress
matter might not even indicate anything
like have you ever seen those one
bouncing left and right those are called
indeterminate progress bar and they
appear when the length of the task at
hand cannot be determinated at least at
the beginning for some reason a very
easy example would be when your web
browser is starting a download and the
server can take you know some seconds to
reply to to actually start the download
and maybe a FR then developer might
stick and indeterminate progress bar
which bounce back and forth until the
actual download gets started and begin
to transfer data into your computer most
of the graphical interface libraries no
matter whether they they are actually
graphic or textual there is always some
sort of widget to represent and have a
progress bar in your program but what if
it's not exactly what you need so
recently I ended up developing a texture
based application which
now currently I still some bugs but I'm
90% done so I need to polish it a little
bit and I'm using this python Library
called textualized that allows you to
develop very nice texture based
interfaces so I need to put a progress
bar in a very narrow space like 10 to 15
characters depending on the size of your
terminal window I cool stick the
progress bar that it's already in the
library and the problem solved that is
exactly what I did at the beginning
however something was missing this
program I made basically transfers files
back and forth for my personal backup
storage and I want to show the actual
download or upload speed in kilo or
megabyte per second if I have this piece
of information let's say next to the
progress bar which already have only 15
characters the progress bar will be very
very narrow pretty tiny what I wanted to
do is to have a progress bar where it FS
on top of the text so the text is on the
progress bar which is something that you
can easily do when you have a graphical
interface but when you have a text based
you know program Things become very hard
to do and this is basically what I'm
going to show today so so before we go
to the code I will show you exactly what
I mean let's say that is nearly
50% done so this is part is somehow
colored I'm not coloring all of it you
will see why in a bit and this part is
still you know to be filled because the
task is nearly 50% done and I want to
have characters on top like text let's
suppose that I want to write my name
that has exactly seven characters which
is v a l e and then after I want to have
with the different colors because when
the progress bar advances by one
character my R the background of the r
becomes green and the r becomes blue why
I don't know you I just get Prov with
this colors but J apart with the style
of the color scheme this is actually
what I want to do because the space I
have is very narrow the only way I can
fit information is on the progress bar
very easy to do when you have many pi in
a graphical use interface but in the
terminal you need to work this around
it's not extremely hard to do but I
don't know why these people haven't
thought about it and probably I believe
that there might be Library providing
that but I I wasn't reaching the point
that the time needed for me to search
what I need it was taking longer that I
said just do myself I have here a class
that I called highlighted uh progress
bar I don't know it might not be a fancy
name but is that the name I came up with
I'm not going through the entire class I
will focus only on the most important
bits so here I have three Conant just to
have an example of you know colors so
the background means the background
color of the unfilled progress bar the
bar is basically the color up to the
point the progress bar has been fil and
the cursor here you will see a bit what
it does let's skip for for the moment so
here I have my Constructor that takes
the essential information of the
progress bar like the total number of
steps because somebody can say 100 step
but it's not necessary it can be
whatever unit you want and the sides is
the actual size in number of characters
of the progress bar and then you have
the three cols that by default I'm
setting with these three examples I have
here so let's go to the core of this
class which is my render method meod
which is here so behind the scene I'm
using another python Library called
reach which allows you to have Rich Text
which has been done by the same
developers of that textualized Library
so basically they came up with reach to
have a very nice colored text in your
terminal and then they came up with that
Library which if you fancy having a look
I suggest you to play around because you
will get very nice applications in in
your terminal so when you render you
basically display a label on top of a
progress bar now for your label you can
also add the placeholder which in this
case my placeholder will be two
percentage symbol which means that
internally this method will replace that
with the actual percentage of the
progress but so anytime two percentage
symbols are found will be replaced with
the I don't know 20 30% whatever it is
here I Define a text to be rendered and
the text class comes from reach which
also allows me to have paddings and
colors so I don't need to do let's say
manually with the control SS of the
terminal and basically here I do the
center right alignment if I needed or if
it's a left alignment I just don't need
to do anything because that comes uh for
free here this is a very important
basically I cut I truncate the text
because as I said in my case I have a
very narrow space and if the TT overflow
I just basically cut it and put the
ellipses basically three
dots which basically is not actually
three characters with three dots it's
one character in um in unic code that is
represented by three dots when is
displayed on the screen and here
basically I have all the bit of code to
calculate the
percentage and here start to make the
style so here what I do exactly is to
fill the progress bar up to the
character n because if I have uh let's
say 10 characters and uh the progression
arrived to 20% I need to fill two
characters so the first thing I do is
boom I'm to the end character so far so
I need to show this and the first thing
is like I feel those characters with the
character of the bar style which
includes the background and the
foreground color because if you remember
there's a different foreground color for
the empty bits for the F bits then here
I display the the cursor so the cursor
is something that I wanted to have and I
will show you in the example that so
when I'm calculating the percentage I
calculate also the number of characters
I need to fill and that is an integer
number so either I F two or three
characters but if when I calculate here
this um n and I can get the next car
percentage I can get flop number
if I need to fill 2.5 characters i f the
Third characters of a different color
just to give the indication that is
going ahead you know it's not like
hanging there nothing is happening then
here I just put two pipes at the
beginning just to have a sense of a
square and the last thing I do is to
fill the whole progress bar with the
background color now some people can say
why don't you do the background first
and then you do all the style it's fine
so because when you rea the start to
everything the previous things youve
done won't be overwritten so stay there
so and I found this quite convenient
when I was writing the this program
because uh I need first to check if the
actual progress part was feeling that
was for me the most important bit and
now here we have an example just very
simple I have a loop that advances the
progress bar by 10 units every time uh I
just put a sleeve of 1 second so it
won't be pretty fast this gives us the
time to appreciate it a little bit more
and I'm just putting 50 characters and
you will see computer file two square
brackets and inside square brackets the
percentage now let me run this and the
help it
works yeah it's working it's progressing
you see when the progress bar goes on
top of computer file the text becomes
black which is basically what I wanted
right and here it's over nothing fancy
well not for the way you see here but in
the program I had it was exactly what I
need said nice now if I have four you
know uploads or downloads I can see each
of them the speed of each of them and
was like spot on now let's see if I can
recreate an example where you can see
this uh csor filling in so let's reduce
the advance by two let's run it one of
the reasons I asked about making this
video originally was I have a camera
Sony camera and when you format or
initialize a SD card it is hilarious and
I will put it on the screen as to what
happens but the counting is in seconds
and I think this is the problem why is
it saying I'm doing it in seconds it is
just hilarious all depends exactly all
depends the how the ETA is um is
calculated so sometimes the way this is
done by some interfaces for what I've
seen by you know digging a little bit in
their code Thea is calculated by what
they call a moving average or
exponential moving a has a width name
which basically
gets the the time for the last
task uh plus the previous time it has
computed divided by two and because the
previous time is always a divided by two
already so if you keep expanding it
becomes by four by by 16 so basically it
weighs more than last task but you don't
know whether your Sony camera accounts
for that or some you know if this C this
task is done we think that it it has two
seconds left whatever yeah because they
have their hardware and they know how
more less it reacts right I think this
is why these Spinners came into being
because you know let's not set
expectations for the person who's the
user you know let's just make a spinner
you don't know how long this will
take because the x86 machine code has
two instructions that allow us to do Dan
one is called erand and the other one is
called stopan abandoned futuristic
cities with over plants right and then I
just put them in a for Loop and just
produce 200 of them so I can pick the
nice ones